hello and welcome to the new world
review where kilwa is going through some
things or coming out of some things
or things are coming out of him i i
don't know how to explain it
so that it doesn't sound like he's
growing an extra limb or tentacles or
hello and welcome to the new world
review where gone is on a date with palm
his first
his last his last happy experience
because after this he'll turn into a
bundle of rage like a screaming toddler
jumping up and down and throwing
fireballs here there and everywhere
who knows find out as we delve into
episodes 94
and 95. episode 94 and it's gone's last
date with palm because
well he was a nice guy it's not often i
invoke the phrase nice guy because it's
a very dangerous one
especially applied to psychopaths which
really tells you everything you need to
know about it gone
was a nice guy in this episode he took
palm on his
mandated girl date while kielwal was
also there wishing it was a mandated
mandate i guess
and we had a lot of cutscenes back and
forth watching kilwa get smacked around
by ramot the silly bunny bird boy who
thought kilwa was actually genuinely
afraid of him and was dealing very
strongly with his own mind
or the threads within his own mind
perhaps it was his brother needling him
all along that was the true friend we
made along the way
his constant companion his brother's
needle which was in his brain
what on earth is this family and why did
he just laugh in that
cilia lumi you played a trick on me
silly if my sister did something like
this to me either i'd never
speak to her again or i would hunt her
down and destroy something important to
her
not a person an item like how she broke
my violator and told me on my wedding
day so i couldn't attack her i never
forget
i just store it up is kilwa going to
store this rage and explode it all over
illumi because i feel like that would be
really quite important to know what's
also important is the shift
that happened in the relationship once
he'd removed that crucial thing keeping
him
safe sort of safe the biggest thing i
noticed in this episode once the needle
was gone was that he seemed slightly
more aloof with gone
not in an unhealthy way either in the
way that says to me
yeah you're my friend and i'll protect
you but that's where it ends because i'm
also an assassin and some of your kid
craps beneath me
that energy in a very real way being
freed of the fear of getting hurt and
the effect of running from everything
announced the fact that kilwa was using
gon to run away from the danger in other
environments too
being able to hide behind gone as a
leader has been a very good way for him
to quietly watch what's happening and
learn the abilities of others around him
while he does it it's probably even why
we've had all this hardcore discussion
from kilwa while gone does
stuff and i guess that's the confusing
point now because most of what we know
of kilwa
is from after the original hunter exam
arc we don't actually know kilwa
not the real one so now we get to meet
that character and see what we think of
him but only for as long as he wants to
be observed the jump from
kilwa's mind to ramat's mind signaling
the shift in power and
scene dynamic was huge and very
satisfying
killa is now free of illumi gone and
vermont and they all noticed it
immediately
remote going from being all powerful to
realizing he was not in fact controlling
the situation at all was very smooth
it's a fitting end to our bunny bird
brain really he was a clarion call that
nen could jump species and that clarion
call has been
ended cut short the first falls does
this mean the others will
maybe but for right now we're still with
gone and palm because we smash cut our
way through
that episode as kilwa tried to use his
mind and connect with his emotions
enough to deal with what was happening
gon took parm on a pretty solid date and
offered her things that would make her
feel safe and comfortable and it seemed
to be something he actually enjoyed as
well but then he tried to be nice
and let her down easy and say hey so
like there's this thing i need to do but
then
afterwards i'm totally down for dating
forever and like maybe getting married
and having some babies i mean he didn't
get that far that's creepy and
he's like i know eight and she's 22 and
i mean he's not eight but like
really still anyway palm that huh face
she gave at the end of act one made me
realize that it had been
too much nice too much comfortable and
kind and of course kilwa was almost
ready to move on to the next part of his
narrative so it was important that we
make the 22 year old
aware of what was going on i've hashed
and rehashed the femme tropes of this
show and it's very obvious that palm has
a similar meme status as a stalker girl
meme
all i want to say is that she could have
done so much better and she's
worth someone legal and who has the time
and space to care for her
needing to take revenge on a kid for
being flighty and gone
shaped is a waste of energy and her
blood is apparently important so
stop rising raising stop raising the
blood pressure the
pressure of old palm you have so much to
give
primarily knives with cheeto's turn
coming up let's head into episode 95 to
see whether he
outruns them or has to outfight them and
whether he can do either
given punchy punchy insurance interest
man episode 95 and i think cheeto will
actually go down pretty easy
as long as they deal with him fast
enough meanwhile we skip to the main
event because that's not the main event
sorry cheeto
kite and gone kite has been found and he
has been
scarred and destroyed gone could see
that pretty quickly in this episode
we've got
a very rare insight into god's head with
some soft
line drawing oh gone allowed kite to hit
him as
punishment i guess i've been finding it
difficult to emotionally connect with
this arc despite all the heartache
that's been going on and i think there
are probably several reasons for this
but
i'm kind of sad about it as well that
said if i'm not crying now it's possible
i'm not supposed to it's entirely likely
that we're still setting up this arc
because i feel like we're not at the
point yet where we know all the
characters and all the players and how
things work something tagashi really
likes to do is faint and hit us from
another angle but like gone he's
consistently inconsistent if i'm not
crying now it's probably because he came
up with something even more
heartbreaking than
watching gone allow kite to beat him to
a pulp
in fact help him beat gone to a pulp
though we skipped from watching gone
getting a beat down to finding out that
he was trying to help the beatdown
happen
pulled me immediately out of the
emotionality of the first part of that
scene and i feel like
the intention might have been to push me
in but it definitely did not
the soundtrack deserves particular
attention in this episode because it
gives us a really good expressive
linking point to respond to and as soon
as i realized the extent to which the
acoustics of the room had been
heightened and the sound of drops that
had been accentuated before the strings
came into play
i turned the sound up more than it was
up already to try to catch that detail
because who doesn't love a good minor
key in acoustic
sound even if i didn't catch the
emotionality even if i wasn't crying
even if
nothing else happened just the beauty of
it was
phenomenal and that was a point i
appreciated this episode
the frames were all individually
captivating the darkness
and the looming puppet master that makes
me think that once if they can
once they've defeated kitty patoo kite
will simply fall apart they're both
thoughts that run through my mind and
sort of have since the first time we saw
kite being played with
that darkness that doesn't fit kite as
expected the debasement of kite has put
a serious flame under god's butt
we return to eyes as themes this episode
kite's eyes have always been a primary
linking point for the character
seeing them in all the forms we do from
shaded to pure white sparking out to
the vacant animalistic remains combined
with the crunching of the teeth when
gone holds him
we get the sense that he's in there
somewhere or we did until
gone stepped back and the puppet master
was there still holding on
similarly we had gone's eyes flick
between their soft brown to the
emptiness that is a hallmark of
emotional shutting down in anime
to the anger he showed as he was leaving
and his own shaded self
we lost gon's eyes this episode which
isn't something that happens often at
all
the character of gone is almost all eyes
they're huge very similar to kites they
take up a lot of his face
we don't go into his mind we see his
mind through his eyes and facial
expressions the harshness and cold of
the tones and the depth of color in the
angry mask was very unlike gone
and yet kind of what i expected for the
first time we got to see the monster
inside
not unlike kilwa's monster assassin self
to a certain degree i have to say that
the ragey face sort of
entertained me maybe because i've seen a
lot of angry toddlers in my time and
because of the youthfulness and softness
about his face he looked somewhat like
an angry child i guess
because he is an angry child no
it's more than that though it's like
he's setting up to have a tantrum and
the rage will flow out of him as he
stamps around the room destroying what
he can get his hands on until he puffs
out and needs to take a nap
moral calling him out to check he was
capable of fighting was an interesting
continuation of that scene and i'm glad
he did it though i think the point of
the exercise was the wrong one
gone still has to learn how to deal with
the fact that his junkie takes a while
to power up and is one hit
he's not or hasn't proven himself as yet
to be one punch man so he needs to be
able to plan for things outside of that
and
honestly what morel did frustrated me a
little we have a kid who failed to beat
someone because of his inflexibility and
when called to prove
his ability displays that same
inflexibility
it doesn't bode well despite his resolve
gone knows exactly who did this to kite
he holds a grudge against exactly them
and he wants
their blood he will do whatever it takes
to kill them or he will die
but i doubt he'll be able to do anything
further the loathing wouldn't be the
same
being able to tap into extreme reserves
doesn't mean he'll be able to do it
consistently and that's the problem i
guess with being consistently
inconsistent he'll one now that he's out
of his brother's needle brain control is
ready and
able to fight to the ex the full extent
of his ability something he hasn't done
for a long time
gone gone is the same gone maybe
stronger yeah
sure maybe he's like plumbing the depths
of his power but the inconsistency is
going to get in his way
getting to spend some time inside gone's
mind shows just how quickly and
instinctively he responds to physical
stimulus
he's incredibly physically intelligent
and aware and the simplicity of the line
drawing showed it to be like a dance
it flowed beautifully with poise and
grace the problem
is that kitty isn't gonna wait and if
they do tagashi's written the character
wrong
up to this point there's nothing in that
cat bug that suggests they'll do
anything other than the smartest
possible behavior and use their
abilities with a combination of instinct
and intelligence
kilwa might be able to balance things
out to tap gone on the shoulder when he
needs to release his barbaric rage but
it will still
i imagine be a close combat sequence and
i think it will be close for all of them
the way these characters have been set
up i'm not sure who we're rooting for
but if we're going with the traditional
version of the protagonist then we're
rooting for the underdogs i'd have been
on the side of the ants truth be told if
the king weren't such a
i think the only other thing that
confuses me is why we don't
have those like kisky and biscuit on the
scene or
any of the hunters we've seen before but
maybe they've decided it's not for them
it's just an odd choice not to bring
back characters we know to engage with
those we know less
and to compare our kids with those they
fought before to see maybe how they've
improved or how they've grown or have
others see how they've improved and
grown
maybe that's who natero contacted i
guess we'll find out soon enough but for
now
that's it from me if you enjoyed this
episode and the random ramblings of a
well me click here here and here for
similar things and hit the subscribe
button
and there's a bell and have a great day
y'all and i'll see you next time